Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to One Night Stand, the game!
Uh, Ryan and Matt actually recommended this one to me
uh, and it's interesting because this isn't normally the type of game I would play,
even though I played Netflix And Chill: The Game
So I guess I don't have any standards on ANYTHING!
But they said it was interesting,
and I'm going to go into it not expecting much
and then seeing where it takes from there.
(reads on-screen text) "My head"
"My stomach,"
"Huh?"
"I..."
"Feel..."
"Like.."
"Crap."
...Okay?
"Last night,"
"What happened?"
OHH, so, OHH
This isn't -- OH, OKAY
This isn't a dating -- ahh, I got it.
Got it. Okay.
"Drink. Lots of drink happened." [Laughs]
I can't drink! I'll DIE!
"AHH! What's that noise?"
I dunno. You tell me!
Probably a phone, if I had to guess.
mmm... "My phone!"
"Where is my phone?"
[Laughs] What is this, Dora The Explorer?
(imitates show) Can you find PHONE?
I have to imagine that it's this.
"Got it!"  I also don't have any glasses, because apparently I can't see anything.
(reads text in a weird, almost British accent)) "MATE,
Whut the ell happened to you last night?"
(Reads other text) "I have no idea but thanks a lot for waking me up." ANGRY FACE
5 percent battery remaining.
"Crap! My phone is about to die, and my eyes are still blurry."
"Better plug it in before the battery runs out."
HOKAYY
"Nope, can't plug my phone into that!"
Watcha trying to stick it up your butt?
Why?
"Or that." Okay..?
"Ahh! My phone charger has to be around here somewhere."
Maybe not?
Well, uh oh!
"Wait.. I don't recognize this bedside table."
*Gasp*
"This isn't my room!"
*Gasps* IS THAT A CONDOM WRAPPER ON THE FLOOR??
KIDS, SHUT YOUR EYES!!!
"My clothes, they're all over the floor."
"Am I..."
me?
"I'm completely naked!
(sarcastically) oh shit, that NEVER happens!
UH OH
ohhh noo
umm
Oh. Hi.
Hello, how are you?
"OHHHH" lemme just shout into your back
[Laughs] "Oh, I guess I got lucky last night!"
"This must be her room?"
(laughing) "I HOPE this is her room!"
It would be an even more bizarre scenario if not!
"But... Who is she?"
Good question!
(terrible accent again) "All the girls were so pissed off."
"I can't believe I ditched my date so you could just bail on us!"
"Shit, sounds like drunk me was up to no good last night."
"Hate to let my mates down, but I guess my mind must have been elsewhere."
"Sorry, I honestly don't know what happened to me last night."
"But guess what?"
"I..." Pulled?
What the hell does that mean?
"Heh, that should shut him up!"
(rough tone)Yeah, bruh!
"Could she be one of the girls from last night that Gary was talking about?"
"Even if she was, I don't know anything about her."
"I can't even remember her name!"
"Shit,"
"I can't really remember ANYTHING that happened last night!"
"I don't even know where the hell I am, right now."
"Ugh, this hangover isn't helping..."
Oh, always the best nights when you drink so much you can't even remember ANY of the fun you had.
(He forgot to use the accent again)"Bullshit, one drink and you're off bedding women?"
"You're gonna need a better excuse for ditching all your mates than that!"
"Gary doesn't believe me, he sounds pretty pissed off."
Huh.. That's weird.
"If Gary's not going to take my word for it."
"I could...Take a  sneaky picture. THAT would shut him up."
Huh. [ Laughs] THAT seems like a VERY morally bad thing to do.
(sarcasm) "HUH,
I WONDER IF I SHOULD TAKE THE HIGH ROAD,
and sneak a picture of this naked lady.
OR
Just tell Gary to SHUT THE FUCK UP?"
Nah, I'm not going to take the picture.
That'd just be creepy. And weird.
And this game is already SLIGHTLY creepy.
"Ah shit! My phone's dead anyway."
"What should I do?"
Uhh,
...wake her up?
I guess.
Why not?
That's what...that's what I'D do, I guess? [Laughs]
"HEY,
who the hell ARE you??"
"AND WHY ARE YOU IN YOUR BED?"
I mean, me.
I dunno.
"I need answers and I need 'em now."
HEY.
Uh-oh..
What the..?
"Did she just throw the duvet over me?"
and HOW DO I HAVE THE CURRENT WARE,
WITH ALL THE...
KNOW THE...
TERM, "DUVET"?
[Laughs] Can I differentiate a...duvet, from a blanket?
"She's...
"She's...gone."
It was a ghost! [Laughs]
I SLEPT WITH A GHOST!
"Maybe she's a little freaked out, about all this."
"I know I am."
"Shit, I didn't really get a good look at her."
...Considering the duvet on my face.
"Maybe she wants me to leave?"
Huh.
Ah..
Oh, hello!
"...This must be her wallet."
"I really shouldn't be looking through this, but then again,
This might contain some useful information about her."
"Drivers License? An ID Card..?"
Again,
With the creepy invasions of privacy,
I'mna [mumbles] ...err on the side of caution.
I'll just ASK  her,
When she fricken' says hi to me!
Uh, "A romance novel, 'Eyes of Embrace'?"
"It sounds...?"
...Intriguing?
"Intriguing. Maybe I should give this a read..."
"Aha!" [Laughs] "I think we've found the cause of this hangover."
"Funny, I don't normally drink wine, especially red."
"I guess drunk me doesn't care, what he's pouring in the tank."
(Poorly imitates some sort of Spanish accent) El Rioja Resverereverja? Sounds fancy..
"It's half empty."
Hello!
Hi.
oh, HELLO
[Laughs]
Ohey...
[mumbles] How're you- How are you doing?
Are you okay?
You okay??
I dunno
"Yeah I'm sorry for dashing out of the room like that."
"I hope I didn't freak you out or anything."
WELL I was only... SLIGHTLY perturbed by the duvet on my face.
"It's okay."
*reading text*
I wanna emphasize how fancy I am ;)
NO!!!!! I wanna talk about this
I wanna share everything with each other.
Oh so she would've noticed if I was taking a picture.
KER-CHUNK!
I don't know who....Bronte is
I think I know Austen
UMMMM
Hangover??
NO! I'm FUCKED up.
I feel awwwwful.
I feel sick.
Uhhh....
Coffee?
Sure...
This seems like such normal life.
This is bizarre.
Nice I guess!
What did happen last night?
HAHAHAHAHAHAA!!!
AWWUAGHHAHA
Okay...anyway
Pair of mah jeans
Odd stains
Hmm...
Reckon they're good for another day or two
HEY if they're like me they would be good for a month to a year
I need to find my boxers.
HELLO again :3
Thank you human
NOT LIKE YOU
I WANNA EMPHASIZE
YOU'RE NOT SPECIAL IN ANY WAY
YOU know...for studying.
OH
HUH?!
What..?
Okay...
Oh okay.
Huuh..
No!
No I don't!
Well uh [markiplier noises] it's not my fault!
I don't know what the hell happened!
Let's see...
Not really, no!
I honestly don't remember a goddamn thing!
YEAH!
Yes! I am!
ANd then???
Well I was part of it!
Still doesn't answer a few questions...
Well me personally, no.
But...
What do I say here?
Nooo?
I don't know this guy's life, why would I know?!
WELL considering I don't really remember anything apparently
Uhhh...
Again I don't! I don't know this guy!
Why would I be in a position to say something??
I don't know!!
My friends are a bitch at me
and my personality which at this point is probably equivalent to a stump!
I'll think about my hobbies
Ugh!
She doesn't want you to talk about yourself!
She just threw up a little bit
Heh she didn't even try and talk and make a clear sentence
Oh this relationship is NOT going to work.
Find anything more about her.
Well there's my boxers.
Oh that's my shirt.
*reading text*
There's a picture of her with someone else.
Uhhhhhh...
Like CRAP!
Well I should've looked at the guitar 'cause that would've told me something about her.
OH NO...
SHE'S PREGNANT!!
OH GOD!!!
Offer to help.
OH okay.
Okay.. OH!
I'll quickly gather-
fklsdffdk
I still can't find my underwear!
What the hell!?
Gonna chill on this bed for a little bit til' I drift on outta here
I wanna see you again!
I guess...
From the...10 minutes we've talked to each other
Hate for things to end like this.
OH OKAY.
UHH.
Sure?
WHAT DO YOU WANT FROM ME?
*reading text*
whhAAT?
WELL WHAT DID I DO?
HUH??? >:(
WHAT DID I DO WRONG?
This is a bunch of bullshit!!
AWWW I didn't save??
AHHHH
Alright I'm going- I'm going in again.
This is SO weird
'Cause it's like a slice of...
Reality, y'know it's just a piece of
normal human experiences
which is bizarre!
Anyway.
[mumbling to himself]
Can we be friends?
Okay that's another way that...
could...wuuhhh?
Okay that's literally the only thing that I did differently.
I don't know!
I don't really know!
What an interesting subject
Bizarre, admittedly, very bizarre.
But an interesting take on like what I said before
like a slice of reality
like this is an occurrence that's not a common occurrence
but it's an occurrence
and there's a lot of different ways you can take it
I suppose that more than anything could be a little slice of a game
I'll leave the rest up to you guys to discover
you could be one way or another in this game
you can treat the scenario with any different number of variables.
So
Try to find it out for yourself!
So uh, I guess that's it
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Thank you Ryan and Matt for suggesting it
AND...I don't know, if I missed something
let me know in the comments below
and let me know what you think of this weird experience
in the comments as well.
Thanks again everybody for watching...
And as always!
I will see you...
in the next video!
Bye bye! :D